necessary here I think it'd be a lot  more simple if I just walk up to the  door alone I think that that would be  why are you under money ban much  bulletin succinct you're not paying  attention if you're messing around with  the gun or equipment Anthony just use  the gun on the table locust unless your  goodness on the table was paid for it  shut up man shut up I'm warning you now  be quiet please  it's true Dignan I paid for the gun say  it again say it one more time  say it again repeat what you just said I  paid for the guy  so dark the con of man no it doesn't say  that  he's doing all that I regret and you  break it moon sermon charms demons Owens  codes monks Rex  rocks my done' up the rocks